visualization the recreation of images
sounds and environments before it has
happened is one of the most powerful
skills in the world a very powerful
meditation and mindfulness practice
visualization has been used for
centuries to help prepare the mind the
body and the Consciousness for upcoming
challenges situations and circumstances
some of the world's greatest athletes
use visualization as a way to prepare
for big games the big day musicians for
their new concerts and tours and CEOs
for their very important meetings lead
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Jay Shetty and my take on his top 10 was
a success enjoy
rule number two make an impact there's
very few creators
of content on social media that started
out with a follow account in mind so me
included a lot of my peers in this space
a lot of people that I know that are
extremely successful on different
platforms none of them started at least
the ones that I know none of them
started to get followers they all
started because they had something to
share whatever that was whether it was
comedy whether it's wisdom whether it
was a workout plan a fitness plan
whatever it was like they had something
that they did that they were passionate
about they wanted to share and I can
only speak to myself fully but when I
started I thought I was going to have a
full-time corporate job and I was going
to make videos on the evenings and
weekends to share a message that's
genuinely all I believed and I it after
my first month I had about a thousand
subscribers on YouTube about four videos
I'd made on YouTube I had about a
thousand people that had subscribed to
my channel and most of my friends were
like great Jay that's where it's gonna
end like congrats well done like you got
a thousand subscribers you kind of just
crept in there in 30 days like well done
that's cool like how far is this gonna
go and that's really the reality of what
it felt like
and the interesting thing is the
question was never how do I get more
followers the question was always how do
I make more content that impacts people
because and and that's the question with
everything it's like if you make more
content that genuinely impacts people
you get more followers if you build a
business that serves more people you'll
make more money if you help a lot of
people through your talents and Gifts
you will be famous and known for it like
it's it's a byproduct of doing something
properly and that's why I love the
definition that Peter diamandis gives
that we should redefine the word
billionaire to be someone who impacts
the lives of a billion people why is
Jeff Bezos the richest man in the world
because he's created a product that we
all say we want and that it solves a
problem that we really need
and so if you want to get followers
don't look at the number ask yourself
are you really creating the value that's
going to help people and they're going
to naturally want to follow you and and
they're going to want to love your work
and share it because
to me that's the worthwhile pursuit in
life because when you do that work that
work is humbling when you do that
creativity that's the part that makes
you grateful for the success that you
get because you go wow like people
actually care about what I have to say
but if you're just obsessed about
numbers and metrics without being
obsessed by the content the creation and
the the service
then then you'll never be satisfied
because there'll always be someone
better than you so for me when I said I
tried this book so many people like oh
so do you do you want this book to be a
bestseller and I said I want this book
to be a bestseller of course I do but
I'm not going to focus on it being a
bestseller I'm going to focus on writing
the best book in the world that I can
possibly write given the skills that I
have and that's why when I talk about
Dharma in the book which is helping
everyone find their purpose Dharma is
broken down Dharma means purpose Loosely
and has many different meanings but one
of them is nature and purpose your true
nature
and the three aspects that I'll share
now for the and there's more depth in
the book The Three aspects of Dharma are
your passion your skills and your
compassion
that's what it means when you have your
passion plus your skills plus your
compassion that equals purpose
but for most of us if we're just looking
at numbers and metrics and data
I mean you'll be dissatisfied that and
I'm saying that as someone who really
values numbers I understand the value of
followers social media I get the value
of all those things and I'm highly
strategic but I'll be completely honest
with you I'm not focused on the number
I'm focused on making content and and
that's the message that if we're focused
on really creating value in the world
all of the other stuff will come
naturally uh you know you you don't have
to go out and separately try and get it
and uh you know wrong and you've done a
great job of this you've made content
that's very organic to you you've made
content that's very natural to you and
and I think that's what people gravitate
towards you and your podcast and your
books because it's you being yourself
you're not trying to sound like someone
else you're not trying to be someone
else and and if you look at the most
successful creators in the world they're
all like that they've just really shared
their raw personality with others rule
number three don't be afraid to start
over I always say it was hard to become
a monk and it was even harder to leave
because I didn't necessarily leave
knowing my natural progression I left
because I realized that wasn't my path
anymore I came to the understanding and
conclusion that I wasn't meant to be a
monk that didn't fit with my purpose and
my calling and externally at least and
then with the people that I lived with
they also felt that I could serve better
and do more for the world if I moved on
but there was no clear pathway and so
when I moved back in with my parents I
had my 18 000 pounds of student loan
debt to pay off I moved back in my
parents age 25 going on 26 because I
didn't have any money to my name and my
resume had bunk on it so I applied to 40
corporate companies like the month I
came back from living as a monk or over
a few months and I was rejected by all
40 companies before an interview because
surprise surprise no one wants someone
with a monk on their resume right it's
like what's your transferable skills
like staying silent or you know being
being mindful who needs that and so
genuinely it was so hard because I was
sending off applications and if anyone
knows corporate applications these are
real in-depth analysis research on the
company and they're not just you know
flog your resume everywhere and so all
these companies are saying no to me and
I'm getting rejection letter after
rejection letter I'm worried that I
can't depend on my parents because
they're not well to do and well after
supply for me for the rest of my life
and now it's like all the people that
doubted me it almost feels like they
were real so when I left to become among
people doubted me and they thought I was
crazy or brainwashed or confused and
they said things like to me you never
get a job you'll never make money again
no one's ever going to marry you like
you know so when I came back
it was almost like all of them were
right I wasn't getting it so I wasn't
making any money again like it was all
true and so my level of self-confidence
and self-esteem in 2013 when I came back
was not high at all and then and then
finally
finally Accenture gave me a job so they
were like literally that 41st company
died just about got I got into the
interview thankfully impressed whoever
was there at the interview and I got
that job and I was starting a job at age
26 that was a job for 21 year olds so I
joined their graduate program
and so I was now five years older than
every single person that was in my
cohort rule number four Find meaning
when you were talking about the stories
we tell ourselves
I think that's so important because
there's a there's a great study there
talk about the book by Amy brzezniewski
from the Yale uh University and what
they found is that they tried to find a
career that they felt people may find
not sharing a positive story around and
they found that hospital cleaners or
Hospital workers potentially are one of
the toughest jobs in wrong and you're a
doctor and you know I'm sure you've seen
people having to do that work and it's a
tough job and so they asked Hospital
workers how they Define their jobs and
the majority of them defined it as low
skilled defined it as you know
insignificant defined it as just a way
to pay the bills and that their job
wasn't useful or their job wasn't
important and their role was basically
describe like the Personnel manual but
then they asked another set of Hospital
workers the same people who did the same
jobs different people who did the same
jobs and they said how do you feel about
your jobs
and these people had completely
different views
they felt they were Healers
they felt they were caretakers they felt
that they were able to transform the
energy of the actual hospital they felt
that they were carers for the people
there
and what they found is that these same
people sorry different people who did
the same job were telling themselves a
different story and therefore they saw
their role as integral to the healing of
the patient and because they saw their
role as integral to the healing of the
patient they found the work that they
did to be extremely meaningful
and that's crazy to think about it that
different people doing the same job
could say different things about the
same work they're doing the same exact
thing daily but someone thinks it's
meaningless and the other thinks it's so
meaningful and this was a term by Yale
that was called the court was called job
crafting the ability to assign meaning
where you see it and all of a sudden
your life becomes meaningful so if
you're sitting in a job right now that
you hate or if you've got a boss that
you really don't like or if you're in a
relationship that you don't want to be
in
if you can't leave for whatever reason
right now because of kovid or lockdown
or whatever it is financial difficulties
if you can't leave and you really want
to
one of the things I recommend you do is
call Job crafting from the Yale School
of Management you start asking yourself
where can I find meaning in this what
can I learn
what can I adopt what is this trying to
teach me and that's actually where
gratitude can be applied to every place
because you start going there is some
value in this I remember when I wanted
to leave my corporate job and I wanted
to live my passion and do what I do
today
but I'm so grateful I was at my
corporate job because I learned so much
there that is so useful to me now
and we find it very easy to be grateful
when things are going our way
but we find it very difficult to be
grateful when things are not going our
way
but what we have to learn to realize
which is a really hard lesson to realize
is that things are always going your way
if you're moving in the right direction
things are not going to always look like
they're going your way and they could
still be going your way we've all seen
curses turn into gifts and Gifts turn
into curses but the problem is wrong and
this is a challenge we have a projector
up here of what we want life to look
like
and then we have the reality of what
life actually looks like so there's this
big discrepancy and so sometimes you're
actually going in the right direction
but because it doesn't look like your
picture and your image of what it should
look like
you work less you become lazier you
become complacent you try less harder
because this doesn't look like the right
direction
but you'll get to where you want in life
just not in the way you imagined it if
you keep going if you keep pushing if
you keep learning and that's what it
means to be grateful in all areas of
your life is trying to even in the
toughest moment
even in a challenging situation no
gratitude like oh I'm so thankful to you
for causing me the pain that's not what
I'm talking about what I'm talking about
is saying to yourself where is there
meaning in this where is the lesson in
this so I don't repeat this again if I
can be grateful in this challenging
situation and I can experience gratitude
at all times then I'm always going to be
coming at things from a positive space
and positive energy also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start are building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five
shift your energy you talked about the
fear of fear and how you had to learn to
let go of your fear of fear what does
actually mean letting go of the fear of
fear yeah so I talk about how we fear
the wrong things
what do we fear so most of us are
fearful of how our friends are reacting
what's happening on social media and
what's the random bit of news that we
heard none of it is fact-based that's
one of the biggest issues the worry base
it's worry based and it's also
imagination based so we become fiction
writers we've all watched too many
movies now we start writing these
beautiful movies in our head we're not
beautiful scary movies in our head of
what may happen so our imagination and
Seneca said it best we suffer twice one
in reality and one in imagination right
we suffer twice and this is what
actually happens to us in the story we
continue to tell her totally now there's
this incredible study in the book that I
have to talk about so they took monks
and they took non-months and they they
competed against each other against each
other literally so they put this plate
where you experience heat and so what
happens is the non-monks touch this
plate now this plate heats up gradually
softly and then at one point it gets
really hot for 10 seconds then it cools
down and so what happened is that when
the non-monks touched it the anxiety and
pressure and stress in their brain just
triggered straight away even though it
wasn't that hot it wasn't hot it was
heating but it wasn't hot to do anything
major to you but the anxiety and stress
in imagination or in anticipation went
through the roof in the non-monks now
this is what's fascinating when the
monks touched it
they showed that it didn't feel anything
as it Rose but as it got to its highest
they felt physical pain but they showed
no trigger of emotional pain because
they did not assign any emotional
element to that pain so my point with
that is you can look at the news right
now and you can get scared straight away
and get incomplete freeze mode feeling
stuck paralyzed whatever it is because
what you're now doing is you're creating
a story of what's going to happen
and that story you can cause sickness in
yourself
not actually the reality the the facts
of the disease hitting you or something
happening physically to you totally and
that story again can be used positively
so your story may actually be true
but if it's going to be true now you can
prepare and that shifts you away from
being scared because now you're
preparing yes and so the real you can be
confident because you're prepared
exactly and so we should be shifting our
fear energy into preparation energy
because what fear does is it keeps you
locked there right we just feel stuck
I'll give you an example like when you
were preparing for big games when you
used to playing the NFL right and you're
playing American football against some
of the biggest athletes in the world
it's like you can either sit there and
be scared that you're going to play this
game on the weekend or you can prepare
and your confidence is in the
preparation so when people go how do I
feel confident right now are you
preparing are you put in the reps are
you putting the reps are you building
your immunity are you taking your
vitamins are you eating lots of water
are you drinking lots of water are you
taking the steps that are needed to
prepare for whatever's coming you will
feel more confident that way rule number
six be supportive I'd say that
when we first met I clearly said to
Riley who I was
what I wanted to do in the world yes and
what that meant for a relationship and
so when we met I said you know I want to
serve the world I don't know what that's
going to look like but I know that I'm
going to choose that above a lot of
other things that maybe the people we're
around are going to choose over their
purpose and I said I don't know what my
purpose is yet but I know that that's my
commitment and that's what I want to
work on and I'd say I've pretty much
stayed the same in that I've always felt
that way and that's accelerated and
escalated and elevated but I'm pretty
much the same but I think the amazing
thing is that when we first met so many
people would have ideas for radhi so
they'd come to me and be like you know
Riley should start a restaurant or
rather she do this or rather should do
that because when we met I was the
ambitious one and driven one and focused
one and Riley was the content one and
satisfied one and I realized that I
loved her for being the way she was and
I wanted her to grow at her own pace in
her own time if she wanted to and then
in the past couple of years I've seen
radhi find herself and want to grow and
put in the work and transform who she is
and that's wonderful to see too and what
I've realized in Partnerships is that
it's interesting often we want to be
around people that are like us but I
always say to people I would never want
to date someone who's like me in that I
wouldn't want to find yeah the female
version of me and marry them I want to
find someone that is who they are and
happy in their own skin and rather he's
been happy with who she was then and
she's happy with who she is now and
that's what allows us to have that
opportunity and a lot of the credit to
our relationship goes to her when we
were in New York and my biggest priority
in New York was setting her up oh my God
Jesus set me up on all these girl dates
literally I would try and find the list
of girls in New York that I think she'd
get along with and then I'd I'd DM them
yeah and I'll be like yeah I think you
and my wife would really get along like
you guys should hang out because I just
felt so bad that she'd left her family
because of me and then now we were in
New York and I would be at work all day
I was a half-post at the time and so I'd
be at work from a nine to six job and
then come back in the evening but then
we might have a networking event so so
much of my pressure on top of building
my purpose was is my wife happy and I've
just I was just always conscious of that
and I just thought if she's not happy
none of this matters and so I was always
trying to find the ways of figuring that
out rule number seven never stop
developing yourself there's another
famous saying I don't know who it's by
but it's um
something along the lines uh
there are very
there are days when nothing happened and
there are days where decades happen or
something like that and it was one of
those times where it just felt like so
much just happened it was almost like so
I'd been doing I'd been making content
teaching speaking meditating researching
and sharing for 10 years up until this
moment so from age 18 when I met the
monk to age 28 I'd been presenting
offline teaching making social media
contents editing social media I've been
doing some for 10 years and that year
that month even before that all the
speaking classes and Performing classes
and everything yeah even before yeah
exactly well it all built to that moment
well in that moment so it was 10 years I
mean 10 years of hard work like kind of
all fructified not in a way that I even
imagined and it was just it was
beautiful like I remember just feeling
like this this amazing feeling of oh wow
and here's the important part the
entrepreneurship part I was
demonstrating my skill it was a skill
that I'd spent way over 10 000 hours
developing both meditation and teaching
and coaching and content
and and that's what I think is so
missing today that when we talk about
passion and purpose and all of these
things and you know this it's it's what
are you deeply actually good at and
skilled at and have an expertise in and
love rule number eight understand the
three s's the three biggest things that
have changed my experience of covid and
I've expressed this and shared this with
so many companies that I've been doing
private coaching with or my own clients
and these three things have really
changed a lot of how they feel and and
they're three really easy things you can
do starting today or tomorrow so you
don't need a lot to make them happen so
they call the three s's the sights the
sense and the sound so what we see what
we hear and what we smell has a huge
impact on how we feel and we actually
underestimate our senses because we rely
so much on our eyes I'll give an example
everyone's been learning maths truth
well like everyone's been wearing a mask
recently
how many of you struggled to understand
what people are saying because you can't
read their lips anymore yeah yeah right
we're so used to looking at people's
lips as they talk that we know what
words they're saying now that we can't
see their lips we realize we're actually
not that great listeners and and our
ears are almost asleep so we rely so
much on our eyes so let me explain to
you what you can change
let's talk about sites what you see
ask yourself right now what's the first
thing you see in the morning
what's the first thing eighty percent of
people they see their phone first thing
in the morning and Lasting in the night
after they see their partner and before
they see them in the morning eighty
percent of us
change it I want you to see something in
the morning that fills you with joy it
could be your favorite quote it could be
your favorite teaching it could be a
picture that your kids drew that you
absolutely love it could be a photo of
your family it could be a work of art
that inspires you I surround myself in
my studio with pictures of places I've
lived people that I'm inspired by
stories that I've told because it fills
my mind with energy when I walk into
this room if I walked in and saw a blank
white wall of course I'm gonna go this
is way more interesting but my world's
more interesting than this to me because
it's meaningful and so the first thing
you see in the morning don't make it
something reactive don't make it a
message or an email make it something
that you've chosen to inspire you that's
the first thing the second thing is the
sense in your life why is it that when
you walk into a spa or you get a massage
you feel relaxed
it's because they have Sandalwood
lavender and Eucalyptus just spraying
out of diffusers and candles and it's an
instant way of feeling calm if you just
inhale on your inward breath for a count
of four and exhale for a count of four
if you just inhale eucalyptus lavender
Sandalwood whatever scent you like from
a diffuser or a candle you will feel a
natural sense of calm in your life and
and feel that Clarity that you need to
drop out of that anxious feeling you may
have and you can have a different scent
in your living room a different scent in
your bedroom a different scent in your
kitchen one that feels right for the
energy you want in that room
and the third and final one is sound
so many of us don't realize the power of
sound
but whether you're listening to your
favorite song or whether you listen to
nature sounds when we were monks we
would rise to nature sounds and we found
that the sound of nature is so at PACE
with the body and the mind and when I
lived in New York I'd often feel
exhausted mentally and I'd wonder why I
I exercise I meditate why is it that I
feel that way and I realized because
it's of something when I researched
called cognitive load your brain is
making sense of insignificant sounds of
drilling of construction work of cars
and taxis and horns and so your brain
doesn't have the power to deal with
what's actually it's trying to focus on
so ask yourself what are the sounds in
the background of your life are they
songs that bring you to life are they
music that calm you down before you go
to bed use sights scents and sounds to
change the state and energy of any
environment in your home and if you
literally walked into every room in your
house and you said what is the site that
inspires me in this room what is the
scent that calms me in this room and
what is the sound that makes me feel at
ease in this room and use sound design
sight design and scent design each of
your rooms with just a candle a picture
and a playlist you you'll transform the
way you feel starting today rule number
nine learn to remain joyful I just find
that so often in a relationship someone
else's success feels like your failure
and and your success feels like someone
else's failure so we project and reflect
both ways and I think it's so important
to realize that no your success allows
for you to create more success for
someone else and Rady's success rather
someone that she's the only person in
the world that I met
that doesn't
react and have horrific mood swings to
stuff like I can have a bad day and come
home and Riley will be doing the
silliest dance in the kitchen and we'll
just completely break the ice and she
finds a way to laugh at anything and
I've learned that from and I realized
that that was a real skill like you can
say that that's just good luck or
someone who's happy-go-lucky it's
actually a skill oh yeah to be joyful
and Find meaning and be able to defuse
the situation and I realize sometimes I
didn't have that skill because I was
overworked or on the verge of burnout or
tired or fatigued or whatever it may be
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is keep
innovating no one cares like this is the
part where
redefining your brand who you are like
your message and reconnecting with
people and it's a continuous thing that
if I lived off of what happened in 2016
I guarantee you I wouldn't no one would
care what I was doing today it's just
not possible and and there's never a
moment where you can ever live off just
a success you had no matter how
successful it was by the way how many of
us know artists that we call obviously
one hit wonders where their song was our
anthem for one summer and now no one
knows where they are or who they are
it's so possible and I've seen it happen
on social media to so many people I've
seen it happen yeah in business to so
many people if you're not constantly
creating and being relevant and
innovating we all know that right we
talk especially especially in the noisy
world that we live in now there's not a
lot of momentum
um and as soon as as soon as you take
your foot off uh the momentum can can
very easily
um Wane yeah I spent that year just
trying to pay the bills and figure that
out but at the same time I always had my
mind in two places so one was how do you
take care of the basics and the second
one was how do I build a real future and
that's when I started talking to more
people and I remember speaking to people
about other different and things I could
do with my skill set and I was very
clear on that I had a real skill set I
was like I only want to make a business
and make money from the skills that I
genuinely have which is content wisdom
teaching coaching this is stuff I've
done for years I understand it I've done
one-on-one coaching I'm I'm uh qualified
as a coach and these are skills I
actually have and so I started speaking
to people and people talk about courses
and people were talking about platforms
and people were talking about programs
and I was speaking about five to ten
people at the time uh one of them
happened to be our mutual friend who you
know Cabot Harrier yeah and was based in
London and Cabot and I actually bumped
into each other at a vegan food festival
that my wife was a part of because of
something she was working on a
restaurant in London and I was just
assisting my wife and Kevin and his wife
had come up to me his wife uh and him
had said that they liked my videos and
my work and so we took a picture
together uh I started following them
back on Instagram because we got along
and then I started to see what Cabot was
doing so I was speaking to a lot of
people who worked in the space of
understanding coaching and program I
think we spoke of that done too yeah we
talked about data yeah but I was really
looking for someone who was also a deep
expert in what they did but were willing
to come and build something with me yeah
so the number one piece of advice I had
at the time was Jay do not work with
anyone you're too important you should
do it all yourself and you should keep
all the money for yourself
and I disagreed with that because I
didn't want to have to build a skill set
something that I didn't have time to at
that time to be honest and I'd rather
work with the pros so for me and Cabot
we built this amazing partnership that
launched 2018 and we became business
partners and and friends and now
attractively like family and we launched
my Genius Coaching program my Genius
Coaching community in Chan 2018. and
that became now that uh business and
Community has been active for you know
nearly three years not only is it a
phenomenal source of income and a
business it's been my most proud moment
of change that we've created in the
world because we have thousands of
people across the world that gain what I
believe are the three biggest change
agents of life coaching consistency and
community so I coach on there every
single week it's a group coaching
session we do it every week without
doubts this has been 52 weeks every year
I'm live in that program every week for
a 40-minute Workshop I teach a
meditation every single week and we have
a community where up until the pandemic
we had meetups in over a hundred cities
every week people getting together in
circles of community so not only is it
such a satisfying business model it's
the most phenomenal way of service
because what we found is people watch
the videos
but then where do they go where do they
go you know what I love
and our challenges arise by how we see
ourselves and what I believe rangid's
referring to is there's this quote that
I begin my book with and that I've
shared in interviews for the last few
years and it's from a writer named
Charles Horton Cooley who wrote this in
the 1900s and what he said is that sorry
I think it's in the 1800s at the end of
the 1800s towards the 1900s and he said
and and bear with me and you've got to
really listen closely to this so when he
said that the challenge today is I'm not
what I think I am I'm not what you think
I am I am what I think you think I am
now just let that blow your mind for a
moment I will explain it I promise I'm
not what I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am which means we live in a perception
of a perception of ourselves so I'll
break it down if I think rangan thinks
I'm smart I'll say I feel smart but if I
think rangan thinks I'm not smart then
I'll say I'm not smart and so the
challenge is that we're basing how we
feel about ourselves on what we think
someone thinks of us and and the
greatest challenge with that is how do
you have any idea
if what you think someone thinks about
you is even true and whether that's even
the best place to start so that's where
our identity struggles we start pursuing
things in life because we think other
people value them it's almost like let's
think of the most playground version of
this
if I remember wearing high-tech shoes
from BHS to the playground right I
remember my mom because my parents
didn't buy me Nike uh trainers or Adidas
trainers which I always wanted you know
we didn't come from that background I
couldn't afford them and my parents
didn't want me to have them so I'd walk
in with my high-tech trainers from BHS
they're about 10 quid or whatever they
were and and and you know to me it
didn't make a difference I didn't really
know at that time whether high tech was
good or bad they were just trainers that
my parents bought me now everyone the
cool kid at school had the latest Nike
trainers all of a sudden I start
thinking that he's now surrounded by
everyone everyone's talking about his
trainers everyone's giving him adoration
everyone's giving him respect everyone's
talking about his trainers so now I
think that if I want to have that same
experience and love from people that I
need to get that
not realizing that I may be able to get
deeper love from people by being kind
and compassionate that I may actually be
able to build a real relationship with
people if I'm loving and and considerate
and empathetic and it's so crazy how
your life can become about pursuing
something and that's why Jim Carrey puts
it best and I'm paraphrasing he says you
know everyone in the world should
achieve everything they've ever wanted
and accomplish everything they've ever
pursued just to realize that it's not
the point now that doesn't mean the monk
mindset is not about not pursuing your
goals it's actually about pursuing your
truest goals your truest self and your
most authentic aligned goals so it's not
about not having goals it's about making
sure that your goals are actually yours
this is probably one of the highlights
of my evening is taking out my five
minute journal the genius J Shetty
version and filling out the rest of the
reflections for the day I found that
this is one of the most calming and
centering moments of my day because it
gives me an opportunity to appreciate
what I have to remember the incredible
moments that have happened throughout my
day see we have so many highlights in
our lives that we forget simply because
we don't take a moment to allow them to
go inward for me this is like taking a
mental and emotional picture of a moment
that I never want to forget and as you
can see today I had the pleasure of
interviewing Jocko willink who
fascinated me with so many insights guy
Roz from how I built this and then
finally just getting to spend so much
quality time with my team I purposely
try to do this in a separate space in an
area that has that grounded energy
remember time has memory and location
has energy when you do something in the
same space every day it builds a habit
it builds an energy it builds a space
and so for me creating that environment
that helps me be reflective and
introspective and great Faithful is
really a big part of it now you may have
heard about something known as decision
fatigue I first came across this concept
when reading the organized mind by
Daniel Leviton it's the idea that we
make so many decisions first thing when
we wake up in the morning that we run
out of energy to make the most important
decisions of the day so usually when we
wake up we're trying to figure out what
do I have for breakfast what am I going
to wear today what do I have to do today
what tasks do I have to finish today and
then by the time you start the tasks
you've already run out of energy life is
challenging it's full of ups and downs
we think I wish things could just be
still I wish things would stop changing
I wish my problems would go away
we want a life that steady with a path
that's flat
yet as Deborah Evans once said life is
like an EKG without the ups and downs
you're not living
because this is what a flat line looks
like and this is what a Lifeline looks
like when we feel those highest highs
those extreme Peaks were ecstatic to be
on the summit then when we're in the
lowest lows those deep values were ready
to submit and so we try and play it safe
and avoid all risks but when we seek
security and prioritize passiveness we
don't realize that a flat Lifeline means
we're dead if we're always trying to
live our lives at sea level then we'll
never see what life is truly about
that what we judge is good and bad are
in fact deeply connected
how could we ever experience how
wonderful happiness is if we never felt
sadness how could we taste the Triumph
of success if we never failed how could
we know the comfort of gratitude if we
never experience loss
somehow we got the idea that being
successful and moving forward in life
means we're constantly moving up
but have you ever read a book watched a
movie or seen a case study like that
they don't exist every story worth
telling has Peaks and valleys successes
and setbacks
our brains are wired for novelty when
something's new whether it's a fantastic
surprise or a huge challenge our brains
light up we thrive on learning and our
opportunities to grow yet our brains
also easily become accustomed to
patterns making it harder for us to
change dramatic disruptions help us
break these patterns and invite us to
see and experience the world in a whole
new way
and as it turns out we designed for
change all the way down to ourselves
your body is constantly being reinvented
replacing most of itself every 7 to 15
years even down to our bones
the universe is constantly shifting and
we are part of that when we try and
resist change it goes against our very
nature
in the Journey of life we experience
Pleasure and Pain there'll be sunshine
and Rain there will be lost in gain but
we must learn to keep moving forward
again and again so if you open your eyes
this morning if you were healthy enough
to move about to maybe get yourself some
food if you're able to go to a
refrigerator and find that it was full
and stocked if you were able to put on
some clothes
and if you had a roof over your head
just remember how grateful you can be
for all those things we consider to be
basic
but for others they don't even have
access to We Can't Stop life's ups and
downs but we can change how we
experience them we can learn to go with
life's flow because as Helen Keller once
said life is either a daring Adventure
or nothing at all what's one thing that
we can do for more wealth so more
abundance in all the areas of our life
so there's a beautiful beautiful
Sanskrit word named mudita and mudita
means to feel Joy in others success so
it's been described that we know how to
feel pain when other people feel pain
that's what we call empathy or
compassion but we don't know how to feel
Joy when other people feel Joy
and in Think Like a monk I talk about
this because I talk about how there are
an infinite number of seats in the
theater of happiness
but because we live in a finite world we
have believed that there are only X
number of tickets in that concert there
are only X number of seats limited
number of seats in that sports game
there are only this many people that
have the opportunity to be abundant
wealthy and successful and as soon as
you put a limit in your mind and believe
that there are only a finite number of
seeds you can't enjoy the show
and so mudita is the perspective of
saying if I can feel Joy for someone
else's success and realize that takes
nothing away from me because there's
infinite number of seats and actually
forget infinite number of seats there is
a seat with your name on it there are
tickets with your name on it in the
theater of Happiness sitting there
waiting for you but because you want
someone else's seat so bad because
you're chasing someone else's seat so
bad and they're already sitting on it
your seats lying they're empty
and so if you just claim your seat
and so if we can experience other
people's Joy if we can uh
look to celebrate other people's
successes and joys then then that will
open up abundance in our life a because
we're now part of their success have you
ever noticed that when you celebrate
someone else's success you're a part of
their success so you're doing that
second you get to learn from their
Journey see when you're envious or you
compare you don't get to learn so you've
lost everything whereas when you
celebrate someone you get to go oh but
what did they do right notice yourself
if you're criticizing someone who's won
or you're negative towards them you go
oh well they've got I've got nothing to
learn from them it was easy from them
who cares about them but if you go wait
a minute they've got something right
what do they do you can learn from them
so the first thing is you're a part of
their success the second thing is you
learn from them
over their journey and the third thing
is you realize that there's a seat with
your name on it and if you can do that
abundance and wealth and everything will
come uh and and you start to follow your
own path as the Gita says which I quote
in the book it's better to follow your
own path imperfectly than to try to
pursue someone else's path perfectly and
so allowing yourself to just chase that
seat that has your name on it is far
better than trying to get in someone
else to see usually during that quality
time with Riley I'm not on my phone I'm
not on my devices but it's at this point
that I finally turned my phone onto
airplane mode I find that this habit is
a game changer and a lifesaver at the
end of the day because it can be so
addictive to just mindlessly scroll
through Instagram or Tick Tock just
before you're about to go to bed and
literally fill your mind up with so much
stimulation that it can be really
difficult to switch off I found that
letting go of your phone an hour before
you go to bed allows you to have so much
more Stillness and calm internally and
externally I really believe that if you
can Master this one habit of not looking
at your phone before before you go to
bed it will truly change how you feel
the next morning they found that 77 of
those who struggle financially play the
lottery right they play the game they
gamble 77 of people who are struggling
financially gamble the advice is don't
gamble if you're gambling right and
you're not winning a lot maybe you're an
online poker player right maybe you're
playing for entertainment that's
different but still be careful but maybe
you're someone who's hoping that you're
gonna get a quick Rich scheme a lot of
these quick writ schemes online aren't
real right and and gambling is just the
more obvious version of that where it's
all gamified it feels exciting but they
found that 77 of people that are
struggling financially gamble right so
the advice was don't gamble don't focus
in on that I think we've come to a place
where we feel that freedom
and the freedom of unlimited choice
is power
and we've all realized in the science
and the studies all show this that the
more choice we have the worse mistakes
we make and we make poorer decisions
based on this complete Limitless choice
and I found that actually when you
Stripped Away some of that choice
your ability to make decisions grew my
meditation teacher said to me even in a
shallow dive you get wet so still do it
beautiful I love that
the first step
is learning to appreciate Where You Are
because if we can't appreciate where we
are we will never appreciate where we
get to and I often say to people like
you're exactly where you need to be and
we're scared of accepting that because
you're like well I don't like being here
but that's because we don't see it as
part of our story and then the third
part of it truly
is that I've seen the most powerful
dreams be linked to service and impact
and so when your dream expands into
having a service element you get the
opportunity to work harder than you've
ever dreamed of you're able to learn
things that you never believed you could
because we're so phenomenal at extending
ourselves
beyond what we know for people that we
love and people we want to serve we will
continue to create the life that we
currently have with the current set of
thoughts wisdom beliefs and ideas that
we have and if we're happy on that part
if you could fast forward your life in
10 20 30 years time and you'd be
satisfied with getting the life that you
have right now then that's great but if
like the majority of people that I know
and that I speak to and that I connect
with online the majority of us would
look and go no I really want to change
life I want to be with my kids but I
want to change how I am with them I want
to be at work but I want to be more
present at work I want to improve the
quality of my life
then I'd say that it's so important that
we learn and open up our minds to
Alternative thoughts I'll give you an
example there's this great study that
MIT did on people's minds openness and
their ability to be creative and
innovative
and they looked at two types of people
one person was surrounded by people who
all knew the same people right kind of
like our normal lives and the other
person was surrounded by lots of people
who didn't know each other
and they did the study around who is
more creative more Innovative and has a
bigger impact in the workplace in their
professional life and then a little bit
into their personal life as well
and what they found was that those
people who knew people who knew each
other who knew them back lived in what
was known as Echo Chambers they were
rarely exposed to ideas that improved
their way of living or their
professional performance but people who
are exposed to ideas that had no
connection with other people in their
life were able to be more creative have
better ideas have more purpose have more
meaning in life so often we've become
closed in our little spaces around what
we hear what we know about and we're not
exposed to this new sense of ideas and
that's what I would encourage is just
approach it with a tiny bit of curiosity
that's all you need one of the reasons
why I love this one is everyone from
Lewis Hamilton through to David Beckham
has used visualization yes so Lewis
Hamilton would visualize the race track
before actually driving in a Formula One
race David Beckham would visualize a
free kick before taking a shot at a
World Cup Tournament and this
visualization allows you to deal with
with the pressure and stress before the
actual activity what it does is it
allows you to fast forward it's almost
like time dilation you're fast
forwarding an experience and bringing it
to the present where you're not
experiencing that pressure and stress
right so that you can engage with it
better so if you're scared for example
for if you've got a really big meeting
or a big pitch coming up
if you live that meeting and visualize
that meeting now and visualize yourself
walking in with confidence visualize
yourself not falling over on the stage
right visualize yourself starting that
first word that you say with composure
with eloquence with Effectiveness then
when you actually walk into that space
tomorrow you're going to carry that
energy with you and this is one of the
biggest mistakes we make that we stress
before right but we don't prepare before
and so visualizing what's about to come
reduces this reduces the stress because
it lets you deal with it now and it lets
you plant thoughts and energy into the
future and that's really what a
visualization is doing right it's
letting you plant the energy of feeling
composed and relaxed now into that
feeling so what I do before I'm about to
go on stage I always visualize myself
walking on the stage and I do that to
make myself feel comfortable and
reminding myself I'm not going to trip
on stage you know which we all fear as
speakers and and it allows me to feel
confident before I walk on so
visualizing any experience a meeting a
lecture an exam whatever it may be a
test whatever it is you're doing and
it's like mental rehearsal totally
that's all it is the mind doesn't know
the difference between something you
fearfully imagine and something that's
real and most people could use that
superpower if you will for something
negative like visualizing something they
fear was going to happen and then
they're actually practicing that in
advanced also totally yeah and that's
what we mostly do we mostly mentally
rehearse what could go wrong right so we
mentally rehearse tripping up ongoing
why would you do that
we we do that because we think we think
dwelling on our stress and pressure
helps deal with it right but it doesn't
dwelling on anything increases it yes so
the only way to deal with it is to
reprogram ourselves you've just been
speaking about this to reprogram
ourselves to deal with it how we want in
the aspirational sense at one point one
of your videos got 365 million views
right yeah one of them is what was that
video that video was a video where I'm
talking about not rushing people's
timelines okay so I feel like we've got
and I was just speaking to someone this
week they're like 25 years old and they
feel the pressure to be a successful
entrepreneur and have a multi-million
dollar business by age 30 and I'm like
why do you feel that pressure yeah but I
feel like now like you know when you're
21 you've got a pressure why don't have
a million followers yet when you're 18
you've got a pressure like why am I not
a tick tock star yet right it's like
there are just so much pressure and that
video was all about how like some of the
most successful people in the world
became successful at 40 at 50 at 60 at
70. like there is no no timeline on
success don't rush it don't rush it and
don't let anyone rush you yeah because
that's one of the biggest mistakes we
make is we go oh my friends already got
this I need to do it and when you start
living as a reflection of other people
you're not living the life you want
you're living the life they want no
questions so that's what the video is
about you can't
plus 30 years ahead
too and I think that's
am I doing what am I gonna be doing when
I'm 50 and it's like well actually
hopefully you'll be doing something that
surprises you
and why not just let your life surprise
you constantly
why make it out like life is like really
a perfect Journey we're like at 30 I'm
gonna do this and at 40 I'm gonna do
this and at 50 and it's like well life
probably is not going to go like that
and that picture that you have rolling
because it won't fit in with what you're
experiencing that Gap is the pressure
that you feel in your life
the reason I'm saying don't put purpose
on a pedestal is because then purpose
becomes this heavy weight that you're
carrying and you're now like judging
yourself that you don't know it and if
you instead make your goal to learn
about purpose learn about meaning
explore yourself experiment grow now it
becomes like oh I'm just experimenting
I'm just learning about myself
if you don't really have an interest
it's going to be really hard and when it
comes to our soft skills we go oh I'm
good communicator I'm just going to
stick to that forget vulnerability or
I'm a really good talker forget
listening and that kind of all comes in
together and I think the point is that
we're always learning and figuring out a
way to serve in whatever situation we're
in that's that's the best route for
Success because that's something that no
one can take away from you we like to
stress out about not being motivated we
stress out by not finding purpose but
guess what just like you've got to eat
and shower you have to find purpose in
every day
I think that we have to get as intimate
with our dark side as possible and I
feel like when you don't get that
intimacy you don't really understand it
I look back and I think why did I do
that and it's just always been my desire
to experiment always been my desire to
learn always been my desire to be
curious and find out more about myself
the first is to approach any situation
of compassion and empathy the other
thing is to recognize that sometimes
when we go through pain it makes us pay
attention like when we go through pain
it makes us pay attention when things
are going great we often get complacent
we stop worrying we get lazy we we don't
worry about anything we're just relaxing
and as soon as you feel pain
pain is a way of your body of society of
the economy to force you to pay
attention so if you're being lazy and
not eating right your body reacts badly
to tell you to stop doing that so any
pain that happens in your life first of
all is saving you from more pain
and so for me that's the shift that we
have to go through and that all comes
from us deeply looking into our minds
and going where are these blocks turning
up from where are they coming from what
are their roots and then how can I
replace them with the the right
conversation the right dialogue
internally when it comes to your hard
skills focus on your strengths when it
comes to your soft skills focus on your
weaknesses if you do those two things
your life will change dramatically
because if you're good at something you
become exceptional at it in the Manu
Smithy which I talk about and think like
a monk it's a monk book and in the verse
it says when you protect your purpose
your purpose protects you
now I want to I want to unpack that what
I mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare Jewel
and a red gemstone
and imagine you were walking around with
the most expensive diamond or jewel in
the world how would you protect it you
want to just like you want to just wait
out yeah yeah you want to just wear it
on your chest like this like a baby
holding it yeah putting a pillow around
a blanket you do like yeah protect it
you'd protect it
and so your purpose is like that and
guess what people are going to tell you
every day that that jewel is not worth
anything they're going to tell you that
that jewel is actually
valueless it doesn't have any impact on
your life they're going to try and take
away that value they're going to tell
you that there's another Jewel out there
that you need to have more value
and what ends up happening is you don't
I love the word look at the wording
protect your purpose you have to protect
it so what happens is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way Temptations
but they can all take you away from your
purpose distractions and to me I'm
repeating this for myself because I'm
like I just want to stick to what I was
born to do and I'm so grateful that I
get to do it I'm so happy I get to do it
and I want to keep protecting it I don't
want to get lost in the waves you know
you don't want to just get chucked in
the waves of the ocean and just get lost
and just not know where you're going so
for me when you protect your purpose
your purpose protects you so that's been
your biggest lesson that's my biggest
lesson why do you feel like your purpose
has been maybe distracted I don't think
it has but I'm saying it so it doesn't
and then you're reminding yourself I'm
reminding myself like I'm preaching to
myself right now especially being in
Hollywood and the temptation of all
these opportunities out here totally and
I think for me it's a bigger lesson also
because it gives me more faith so I
always encourage and this is actually
this is why it's my biggest lesson I
encourage so many people that I coach so
many people I Mentor obviously everyone
in my community and audience and
everything to go and follow that go and
live that purpose and I see time and
time again that when I see people trying
to live their purpose they are protected
that it things work when you're playing
in your Dharma and your purpose things
work things move you feel momentum they
happen and I'm not saying that happened
without effort but they happen they move
whereas when you're not you just
constantly feel like you're grinding up
against you know a war I think of
inspiration like eating food every day
you feel hungry
and you don't panic when you get hungry
you just know you need to find food and
eat but you don't go oh no why do I feel
hungry today I ate so much yesterday and
I ate so much last week I shouldn't be
hungry today like why do I feel hungry
today that's not your Panic your Panic
is why didn't I plan for my meal right
like that's the panic but you're not
panicking going oh my gosh why am I
hungry I shouldn't be hungry so it's
really strange when we don't feel
inspired or motivated we we Panic we go
oh no why don't I feel inspired I'm I'm
a negative person like I'm I'm not
motivated like what's wrong with me well
that's because we haven't fed ourselves
and so we have to find something that
inspires us daily you may say uh it's a
quote that you see that you write your
favorite quote you put on a Post-It note
next to your bed when you wake up in the
morning it may be a paragraph from a
book you may be listening to this
podcast
two of my best habits for inspiration
with these two that I want to share with
you Melissa one of them was around
I probably said like around seven years
ago when I left the when I left monk
life I would every day I would listen to
Steve Jobs's Stanford commencement
speech every single day to the point
where I almost knew off by heart
and I cannot tell you how much that
rewired the voice in my head
and how much of that speech has inspired
every step and decision I've made today
I had the fortune the other day of
sitting down with Matthew McConaughey on
my podcast I was interviewing him for it
I think the episode comes out next
Monday and I was telling him that at one
point in my life in about 2014 2015 I
listened to his Oscar's acceptance
speech and it's about five minutes and I
would listen to it every single day for
30 days and it was so profound listening
to the same thing again and again and
again to rewire my mind so inspiration
can come in all ways whether you're a
auditory learner or a kinesthetic
learner or a visual learner the point is
you have to feed yourself every day
whenever you give out any energy love
hate anger kindness you will always get
it back one way or another
love is like a circle whatever love you
give out
it always comes back to you I was just
showing Sally a Facebook memory
backstage seven years ago I love
Facebook reminders look at this it
showed me that I was speaking to this
little group of students about seven
mistakes people make in their 20s
and it was a memory of a talk that I was
giving six and seven years ago I
released my first video five years ago
so six and seven years ago most people
didn't know who I was and what I was
doing had an event in London called
conscious living it was on a Friday
night in the city and five to ten people
would show up every week that's it five
to ten people and I remember loving it
and I remember feeling so happy and so
grateful that five to ten people showed
up and I feel the same way about the
first five to ten people that followed
me and commented on my videos and I feel
the same way about the first five to ten
people when I finally got to meet them
and I found that if you can love one
person if you can deeply feel grateful
for one person
then thousands hundreds of thousands
millions will come from that but if you
struggle to be present and connected to
that one person it's really hard to be
trusted by the universe with more what
is it that success looks like for you
and don't make it about a number don't
make it about an account of views don't
make it about a follower don't make it
about a size of home because those
things are great for success but they're
not great for happiness my measure of
success is can I wake up and do
something I love every day Harvard did a
research study on 3 000 leaders managers
individuals working inside organizations
and they looked at the top performing
ones and they wondered and asked what
was the number one skill they had
and it came down to this one word
associating the ability
to connect dots where people usually see
differences
the ability to find parallels and
similarities and synergies where other
people only see divide and disconnection
we live in these Echo Chambers inside
our organizations we get lost around the
same group of three to four people we
get lost in the same mini groups of
people and we don't expand our minds
beyond that people with broader networks
people who had people in their lives
that were very different from the other
people were actually able to provide
more creative more productive more
effective ideas and Solutions in the
company because they were able to look
at things from multiple angles different
perspectives how can we start to
recognize
that when we win and someone else wins
when we win together when we're able to
help and serve and support each other
together
that so much more can happen I from a
very young age just felt
there was this strong inner voice and I
believe everyone has it this isn't me
being religious or spiritual or woo-woo
this is me saying that there is a voice
that we all hear in our minds in our
hearts in our heads wherever you want to
say it is it's there and
the challenge that happens is in our
early years you're told to tell it to be
quiet so every time that voice says well
maybe no no no no no just just do what
they're saying do what they're told
get on that conveyor belt get on that
assembly line
stick that barcode on your back become a
machine go be a robot and and it's
almost programmed and so that voice that
is not machine like that voice is the
human inside of us is being trained to
be a machine and so we start treating
ourselves like machines and machines you
just program them and then press enter
and then it gives you what it wants but
we don't function that way we're a
conversation in the universe we're not a
program and so if you're a conversation
and you're an interaction you're dynamic
that inner voice becomes so squashed
that now by the time we're 20 30 40 50
60 70 whatever age you are you can't
hear it anymore so you say oh that's
some spiritual mumbo jumbo stuff because
I don't hear that voice
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing Ed mylett video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I love
Toronto that's one of my favorite cities
on Earth that's like one of the most
beautiful modern great cities in the
world so by the way I want to tell you
one thing your uh your content is so
good that's why I mean